more breaking news now for you this
afternoon let's take your life to
Glasgow police giving an update
following the death of a pregnant
primary school teacher Morel story I
thought Sir with Mariel's family and
friends and along with everyone affected
by this tragedy
we are providing her family with
specialist support at this incredibly
difficult time
her partner David Yates is wanted in
connection with Middle's death
at this time we have no information to
suggest anyone else has been involved
his vehicle which was a white seat I'll
take her
was found at mugdock Park on Tuesday and
an extensive search has been ongoing at
that area since
the last confirmed sighting of David was
on Sunday evening shortly after 8 pm
his subsequent movements are unknown
after his vehicle was left at mogduk
Country Park but there is nothing to
suggest he has left that area
we will keep an open mind on this as we
continue to search the area
a visible police presence will remain at
both Modoc Country Park and jurora
Street as we continue our investigations
that is not believed to be any risk to
The Wider public however I would urge
anyone with any information or concerns
to contact police Scotland on 101
quoting instant number
0904 of the 25th of April or speak to
any of our officers
and finally and importantly
I would like once again to express our
sincere condolences to Mireles family
and anyone else affected by this tragic
incident
thank you
as you can appreciate the investigation
still ongoing so there's some
information I can't provide at this time
as I said this is an an ongoing murder
investigation so I can't provide that
information at this time
David Yates
what business are you putting the
investigation on at the moment is your
day or is he alive as far as your
concern
both of those factors still play very
much a factor and if I can't confirm one
way or the other what it is however they
are both working lines of inquiry at
this time
Country Park at all as I've said in my
statement his car was found here on
Tuesday and that is where research has
been has been progressing and at this
stage we have no information to suggest
that he's left that area
again though I would like to stress that
there is no wider risk to the public
I have no idea where the pet stalks were
about as well at that time packages
from the information of God from that we
have just now I can confirm that there
is no
wider risk to the public could you let
us know when um
I can't provide that information whilst
we've got the ongoing criminal
investigation
police before this incident as you can
appreciate this is a live murder
investigation as I've provided in my
statement so I can't provide any of that
information just now
leaving the house
as part of an investigation the
information that we have is we've got
our last sighting of them at eight
o'clock
last time where was that last night the
last seating all of them was
um
near to magdock park is probably the
best way I could provide that just now
and as I say with no information that
would indicate that he has left that
area at this time is there any
indication as to believe why he's killed
him in Portland OR
as I said this is still very much forms
part of a live murder investigation so
that I'm very limited to the information
that I can provide to you at this time
again that forms part of our ongoing
investigation do you know when she may
have died whether it was over the
weekend Monday which is what can you
give us any indication
at this stage no I can't wait
so in regards to
the murder investigation I can't provide
specific details at this time what I
would like to provide is we found this
car at mugged up Park on Tuesday and
that is where we have formed our
investigation sense we have no
information to suggest that he's left
that area
um and again I would just like to stress
to reassure the public that there is no
way that can sense
as you can imagine this is a very
difficult time for Middle's family and I
would ask for her their privacy to be
respected at this time
um it's very difficult and tragic time
we're using extensive resources just now
as you can appreciate modern Park is
quite a significant area in itself so
there is quite a large Place Presence at
this time
um again that's part of our criminal
investigation
um so obviously as part of our
investigation we have a number of lines
of inquiry being progressed and that
would form part of that
all right okay
thanks everyone thank you
police Scotland there in Glasgow with an
update on the murder investigation into
the death of morel starrick the heavily
pregnant teacher police say they are
looking
for her fiance so police Scotland
confirming a murder investigation is now
underway
foreign
we're hoping to speak to our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis in just a
moment who is at that press conference
and can bring us a little bit more but
this is just truly horrific case um
police are now looking for the fiance of
the 35 year old teacher who was murdered
in her home on Tuesday Morning in the
city of Glasgow and they have been
looking for her fiance in the area of
mugdock Country Park
officers are saying that Ms Stark's
death is being treated as suspicious
inquiries remain ongoing but as we heard
there at that police press conference
there is not deemed to be any risk to
The Wider public it was a Manhunt we're
now hearing it is a murder investigation
and police officers are currently
searching for her fiance David Yates
um just looking there at the image of
morel starrick the heavily pregnant
teacher murdered on Tuesday Morning in
the city of Glasgow let's bring in
Connor Gillis who was at that news
conference which just wrapped up a few
minutes ago and oh gosh Connor this is
just such an awful story um just worth
reiterating to viewers who are just
joining us uh what police told us in
that news conference we've got the
latest from them
yeah let's just guide you through those
details revealed by the lead detective
in this investigation in the last number
of moments we know that Morel sturrick
died on Tuesday her remains were found
around 8 40 in the morning she failed to
show up to her job at school it's only
the last sighting of her was but
Neighbors in the area told Sky news this
morning that they had a conversation
with her on Friday so that will be
forming part of this investigation as
detectives as those specialist officers
pieced together her last known movements
at some details around her as a person
we know that she was a much loved much
respected teacher at a nearby school was
very into her musical theater and
enjoyed the Performing Arts we also know
tragically that she was 29 weeks
pregnant when her life came to an end
early on this week she was murdered and
those detectives are trying to find out
who buy what they are interested in
finding out is the whereabouts of her
partner David Yates let me just talk you
through some of the details he was last
seen in the mugdoc Country Park area
which is around 10 miles north of where
the pair shared a home in Glasgow in a
wooded area it is a large area 600 acres
of land and it has a number of
reservoirs in there as well deep water
and detectives have been scouring that
scene extensively over the course of the
last 24 hours or so they are now saying
that in connection with this murder
inquiry that they need to trace him
however they do not have an idea as to
whether David Yates
is alive or whether he is dead at this
point in time neither of those can be
ruled out according to the detective
leading this investigation we do know
though that his white seat car was found
at the mugdoc Country Park area on
Tuesday of this week and that has the
reason that is the reason that
detectives have been scouring that area
this is a now major Manhunt taking part
in various areas all around Glasgow
but tonight there is a family who are
without their daughter their sister and
detectives are trying to find out who
took her life
connellis thank you